so we've had less to impart school for
five years now since 2010 there was some
of our students that come to our school
your classes that actually come back for
the intensive classes just to give them
a an extra boost in terms of their
grandma mostly in terms of their
confidence for using the language all of
the work that we do is a balance with
the four different skills reading
writing listening and speaking we use
all of them in the classes in the
literature and in the skills one so that
the children can get the most out of
their time with us I came to the British
consul because I won't speak English
fluently I want to work in an English
countries like Britain or USA in the
morning we learn about grammars rules
and in the afternoon is about literature
and we read books and talked about a lot
of subjects we can give our opinion
about a lot of topics
so we make up the class groups by age
and by level all the students have to
take a placement test and then we group
them by their ability in English and by
the French school class in fact
there's a great space for the children
to play it's very important in the
breaks that they can get outside and get
moving and it means that we can use it
as well for example for our presentation
on the final day
it's a great opportunity for them to get
to know each other to interact and also
for them to really move around which
obviously helps their learning in the
classroom
at lunchtime I can go home for those who
live nearby those who bring their own
lunch they eat on the premises and
they're supervised i will recommend it
to my friend because it really helps you
to improve your english my assuring
afternoon is a very fence we can
progress a lot in a british consul